Okay. And so um getting getting to this
this weeks and today's lecture. So from
a usual road map over the last few
weeks, we started looking at kind of uh
modern ways to approach learning based
control. We started from imitation
learning where the idea there was to
learn to mimic um the behavior of an
expert. And then last week we started to
introduce reinforcement learning which
is this idea of learning through trial
and error and specifically we introduce
some uh foundational learning mechanisms
uh to do so and starting today and for
the next uh lectures for the remaining
lectures of this class we'll be looking
at specific categories of algorithms uh
today starting from value based methods
that belong to the category of model
free reinforcement learning methods.
Uh so uh briefly mention a couple of
amazing references. Of course you all
know kind of probably Satan and Barto's
textbooks on reinforcement learning but
also this course by David Silver which
is which is great and also some some of
the slides today are indeed inspired uh
by that course.
So uh to briefly um pick up what we were
saying uh last week. So remember that in
in previous lectures we basically
starting started to make the distinction
between uh what we refer to as
prediction whereby given a policy that
was given to us uh we wanted to estimate
the value for that policy and uh control
whereby the goal which is actually what
we deeply care about is to learn the
policy that optimizes some measure of of
performance. And specifically we started
looking at um uh algorithms motivated by
dynamic programming which we refer to as
exact methods specifically policy
iteration and value iterations as ways
to solve uh mark of decision processes
um which is indeed the mathematical
formalism we are using also for
reinforcement training.
And we also highlighted how these models
despite being great at solving macro
decision processes had one main
limitation which is the one that we in
order to use them we assumed we have the
a perfect knowledge of the system
dynamics. Specifically we have knowledge
of the uh transition function t which is
the probability of going in state xt
plus one given in state xt given action
ut.
And so uh basically last time last week
we started to introduce two really
fundamental uh learning paradigms to
which really encompass this idea of
reinforcement learning which is learning
from interaction. Right? So we don't
have access to a dynamical model. We
want to learn uh without it through
interactions from the environment. And
we saw specifically Monte Carlo learning
and temporal distance learning as two
key instantiations of these learning
paradigms.
we started building out even visually
kind of a mental map of different
approaches to learning from interaction
whereby we were looking at these um
diagrams uh which essentially represent
rollouts in our environments. So if you
recall in these diagrams white nodes
represent states and black nodes
represent possible actions that we could
take in that specific state. And so
these basically uh kind of visualize
this idea of the possible futures that
we could have in our environment. And
ideally when we look at estimating the
value of a state given a policy we are
potentially ultimately interested in
estimating the expected value over all
the leaves in our possible rollouts.
Right? So this is the actual quantity
that we're interested in in estimating.
Of course, kind of one uh way assuming
we have infinite compute would be to
just simulate our uh environment
infinitely many times forward collect
the actual expectations of all of the
leaf nodes and estimate the values like
this. But then we saw how dynamic
programming gave us uh through the
principle of optimality gave us a
practical way of approximating and
calculating actually these um these
values through uh basically a one-step
uh calculation whereby the value of a
given state uh was essentially defined
as the expectation uh of the reward that
we observe in the onestep transition
plus the discounted future value at our
next state.
The catch here is that to compute those
expectations exactly, we needed the
knowledge of the transition function or
our dynamics. And so this is where Monte
Carlo and temporal difference learning
came in place whereby we used sampling
that is we simulated some rollouts in
our environment.
And in Monte Carlo, we update our guess
of our value function by taking a step
in the direction of the return GT
where we calculate this GT simply by
having a roll out in our environment
until we reach a terminal state and
summing up all of the rewards that we
observed uh in this roll out.
In TD uh on the other hand we define the
uh target uh by basically getting
leveraging ideas from both Monte Carlo
that is the sampling and dynamic
programming that is the bootstrapping by
defining the target as this one-step
estimate of the of the final return.
And so we saw how um compared to dynamic
programming which has no need to sample
because we have the underlying dynamics,
Monte Carlo and temporal difference
learning both sample because we do have
interactions in our environment.
And we saw how uh TD and dynamic
programming bootstrap because they
update the guess towards another guess
which is our estimate at the next time
step t plus one. Uh well Monte Caro does
not bootstrap because it actually rolls
out until the end of the episode. Of
course, we introduced everything in this
slide for the purpose of estimating
value functions or state value functions
V. But everything that we just said
holds equally for state action value
functions or Q functions.
Uh for control, yes
or like is there anywhere you go and you
take like five steps and then reevaluate
that you always need to reach a terminal
state. uh which is indeed if you wish
one of the limitations of of Monte Carlo
uh but we discussed trade-offs between
bias and variance of these estimators
but yeah
uh but so this is great for the purpose
of prediction that is estimating values
given a policy but what we actually care
about is uh finding those optimal
policies themselves right so we care
about control and so we discussed kind
of a general paradigm for um for control
which is the one of generaliz policy
iteration whereby uh the main idea here
is that we are alternating between two
different processes. So we're given
arbitrarily initialized value function
and a policy and we alternate between
policy evaluation step that is given the
policy we estimate the value function of
that policy and a policy improvement
step which given the updated value
function uh kind of uses it to carve out
a better policy out of it. And by
iterating through these two processes,
we hopefully converge to the optimal
value function and associated policy.
Specifically, we saw kind of a vzero uh
version of a working control algorithm
which we refer to as Monte Carlo
control, which is basically alternating
between two specific instantiations of
these of the policy evaluation uh
process and the policy improvement
process. For policy evaluation, we are
essentially using a Monte Carlo estimate
of a Q function.
Well, for policy improvement, we assume
to do an epsilon greedy policy if you
recall. So again, we saw this general
formalism and then we had like a vzero
RL algorithm which we denoted as Monte
Carlo control where we had two specific
instantiations of uh policy evaluation
and policy improvement.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay. So today what we'll essentially be
doing is we'll be building on top of
these concepts uh by first of all
introducing two very popular algorithms
uh of like falling between the family of
value based methods which is SARSA and
Q-learning. Uh we'll use the discussion
on these two algorithms to deep dive and
explore a bit more in depth the
difference between on policy and off
policy algorithms. we'll see more
shortly. Um, and then we'll introduce
value function approximation as a way to
scale these algorithms to higher
dimensional state and action spaces.
And we'll conclude with a brief mentions
to some deep reinforcement learning
methods and and applications.
All good with the plan.
Nice.
Okay. So
we basically discussed Monte Carlo and
TD learning and we and last week we
mentioned how temporal difference
learning essentially has if you wish
several advantages over Monte Carlo
learning uh to some extent. The first
one is that uh we saw how TD learning is
a lower variance estimate of the ground
truth uh return. So remember that we
were making this even visual distinction
whereby assuming we have a roll out in
our environment until we reach some
terminal state at time t
um in Monte Carlo to estimate the
expected return for for our policy we
would essentially be rolling out the
entire um episode until we estimate we
until we're able to compute our target
return GT which is simply the uh
discounted sum of all the return rewards
that we observed over time.
Um and we saw how this target which in
Monte Carlo is simply the return for TD
we basically used
the kind of a dynamic programming
estimate whereby
our target becomes the instantaneous
reward plus the discounted future value.
And we last time we basically
highlighted the fact that by looking at
the amount of stoasticity that is
involved uh TD learning is a lower
variance estimator because simply put
we're sampling only once while in Monte
Carlo in order to estimate all the way
down here in our episode we would have
to account for the added stoasticity
that comes by sampling in our
environment uh for further further along
the way essentially.
Not only that, we also discussed that
since in TD learning we are working with
onestep uh updates, we can use this
update online. That is as we progress in
our uh rollout, we could keep updating
our estimates of the value function and
because we don't need a terminal episode
um we can work with incomplete sequences
essentially.
So
uh long story short uh we have a number
of advantages from TD learning. So kind
of a natural idea would be how do we why
why don't we just replace in our Monte
Carlo control algorithm that is our V0
RL algorithm um TD learning where we
previously had Monte Carlo learning of
our Q function
and basically this is essentially the
the step that leads us from our Monte
Carlo control algorithm to what is known
as SARSA.
So let us look a little bit more closely
at what it means to update action value
functions or Q functions uh within this
algorithm known as SARS. So specifically
we referred before to the temporal
difference backup as updating our guess
of our value function by taking a step
towards the TD target. Of course this
holds for um value functions V but
equally for Q functions uh in the same
way. [snorts] Of course, the moment we
want to define this uh TD backup for Q
functions, we need a few specific
elements, right? Uh which are
essentially the we need the current
states and control XT and UT. Uh we need
the reward that are obtained from those
uh by taking that control on that state.
Uh and then we need the future state XT
and the future uh the future control
that we take uh at t + one.
But once we have this, this is
essentially what defines the um Q
function update uh in uh in this
algorithm. So specifically now just a
note on on notation in reinforcement
learning literature al uh the this
squint of events is usually expressed
with uh states represented as s and
actions represented as a. And so if you
take this quintuple of events which are
the ones that we need in order to define
this update, this literally spells out
SARSA. And so this is also where the
name of the algorithm comes from. But
again kind of kind of simply put at a
high level what we're doing is that now
we took our Monte Carlo control
algorithm. We replaced um Monte Carlo
evaluation of the Q function with TD uh
TD updates of the Q function. And we're
doing this at every time step because
this is something that TD allows us to
do.
And so indeed you see that the kind of
the step from what we're doing to
arguably one of the most famous
algorithms out there SARSA is indeed
pretty small, right? And so uh I think
it's useful to go through pseudo code to
really uh ground uh our our intuition.
And so this is uh if you wish how SARSA
is loosely defined. So we initialize a Q
function again this could be all zeros
at the beginning um
and we start our learning loop. So we
are initially uh initialized in our
environment at some state xt.
At that state xt we choose an action
according to our greedy policy or
epsilon greedy policy. So remember that
we
discussed how our policy pi if we choose
an epsilon greedy policy is something
that for with probability epsilon we'll
choose a random action
and with probability 1 minus epsilon
we'll instead choose the arg max
over u of our uh q function.
So we are in a in a given state. We act
according to our epsilon greedy policy
and pick an action U. Um this will lead
us into will basically give us a reward
for that action and next state from
which we repeat kind of the set the
selection of our control UT plus1
according to our epsilon GD policy. And
now we basically collected all of our
five elements that we need for our uh
update. Right? So we have the initial
state and control XT UT. We have the
reward associated with this control and
the following XT plus1 UT plus1.
And so here we just simply compute this
update rule that we defined previously
which is nothing else than the uh TD
backup for uh Q functions.
Of course, here the clock ticks and we
kind of repeat until uh until we
converge.
Any questions here? Does it make sense?
>> Yes.
>> Uh yes, indeed. So here we're using kind
of a TD version of our update for the Q
functions where we are updating our
value functions according to the
basically one step look ahead you might
say right so we're taking one step in
our environment and as we were showing
here in our you know pictorial diagrams
we're essentially using only this oneep
update to update our values.
Okay.
Okay, so let's uh dig a little bit
deeper and let's build some intuition
into what we're actually doing here and
what are the results from the
perspective of the policy that we
actually learned. And so let's go
through this uh what I'm referring here
as a windy grid world example. So here
we are in a grid world where we the goal
is as usual to go from a starting cell
to a gold cell G. Um the policy uh or
the action space is basically uh the
four cardinal directions.
And in this grid world kind of the catch
is that we assume we have some kind of
fictitious wind that is coming from
below which basically pushes uh the
agent uh x cells up depending where x is
the value encoded here below each of
these columns. So for example, if we
were in this column here in the third
third one, we would have no wind. If we
were in the fourth, we will be pushed
one up and so forth.
As usual, the goal that we want to solve
is to basically come up with the policy
that uh reaches the goal in the minimum
time possible. And we encode minimum
time through a stage wise reward that is
negative one for each uh tick every time
our clock ticks essentially. And we have
some specific hybrid parameters. Uh
epsilon refers to our epsilon greedy
policy. Alpha is the step size of our
update. And we pick a gamma of one.
Okay. So now even just by eyeballing
this uh uh this uh example, how would
you describe the optimal policy here?
>> Yeah.
part of the thing or you turn around.
[snorts]
>> This is a good intuition. It's actually
not correct in this case. Um, can anyone
spot why?
>> Yeah.
>> You can't move over and up in the same
bottom push
by there.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Because if you look
closely at the kind of the intensity of
the window here, if you're way all the
way to the bottom here, you'll basically
go up here, then you take one step and
you go up again. You take one step and
you go up again and then here you'll be
taking two steps, right? So you you
won't be able to reach. So actually it
turns out that the optimal thing to do
will be to just push yourself uh to the
ceiling and then go back and so here go
back here and then ultimately go to your
goal.
So here you know here's where I ask you
to do a leap of faith but if you
actually implement this in practice uh
what you will see is something that
looks very similar to what is here on
the slide uh whereby the first of all
SARSA indeed does converge to the
optimal policy which is similar to how
we described it. Um, and by looking at
the training dynamics, we will see
something similar to this plot on the
slide. Specifically, this plot is
showing on the x-axis the time steps of
interactions with the environment. So,
literally how many time steps we are
observing in our environment and on the
yaxis we have the number of successful
uh episodes meaning how many times do we
actually reach the goal. [snorts] So you
will see that initially our Q function
is and therefore our policy is randomly
initialized. So we'll basically be
succeeding zero times. So we never reach
the goal until at some point even just
by random exploration. Um we will reach
the goal. And here's where kind of the
magic the magic of the uh TD backups
start to happen because through those
backups we're basically starting to back
propagate the uh basically positivity
and the goodness of our decisions all
the way back to the starting point. And
so you will see that over time kind of
the performance of the policy improves.
Does the do the graphs here make sense?
Now would you say that the so would this
within this environment would you say
that Monte Carlo methods would also
easily apply
and in either case uh why do you think
so?
This is kind of a a more subtle question
but I think it's it's a good one to uh
to think about. Yes,
>> it wouldn't be the case because it would
try and accommodations and you only
terminate it once you reach your goal.
So the goal is that you spend a lot of
down time just having to kind of wander
around until eventually go.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I would say this is
definitely the right intuition. Uh
because in in Monte Carlo methods
remember we require terminating
episodes. Well, in this case terminating
episodes is only when we reach the goal,
right? So uh we might be lucky in the
sense that we end up into uh you know
some random exploration that does reach
the goal but in the general case it is
not guaranteed that we'll be able to to
do so right so I think like um
a nice counter example to think about is
um
say that in our
grid world example we have a situation
whereby for some uh you know behavior of
our learning dynamics, we converge to a
temporary policy that is uh something
like this,
right? Something where we have kind of a
a circle loop uh in our policy. Then in
Monte Carlo, this will essentially never
update the Q function and it will be
stuck in this loop. On the other hand,
if we are in the same situation with
TDarning, TDarning allows us to uh
update online, right? So at each step,
we are actually updating the values in
our Q function. And so this means that
if we were to be stuck in this circle of
loops, at some point we are basically
acrewing negative rewards over time. And
so this would mean that these specific
behaviors at some point will be actually
worse than doing something else. indeed
and so it's exactly as we said in the
sense that termination is not guaranteed
for all policies here and therefore uh
kind of success of MC Monte Car learning
is not guaranteed as well.
Okay. So
we now introduce if you wish one of the
kind of kind of one of the first
complete reinforcement learning
algorithms namely SARSA. Let's use SARSA
as a kind of grounding algorithm to
start discussing the differences between
onpolicy and off policy learning. So we
mentioned it briefly before but let us
briefly revisit also the definitions of
what we mean by uh on policy and off
policy learning. We'll dig more uh later
on this but this is kind of at at high
level how I would describe on policy and
off policy learning. So for on policy we
mean that we are interested in
evaluating or improving
the policy that is currently used to
make decisions in the environment.
On the other hand, for off policy, we
are interested in evaluating or
improving or improving a policy that
might be different from the one that is
used to generate data. That is the one
that is actively interacting with the
environment.
Again, we'll formalize this a little bit
shortly, but I think this is intuitively
kind of the main difference.
Now with these two kind of loose
definitions,
in which of these two buckets would you
place SARSA? And and and also and again
here uh why would you do that?
[snorts]
So we are
modifying it. Um but I would argue that
we are modifying the policy that is
actively being used in the environment.
Right? So I'm I'm kind of giving away
the answer a little bit. uh but in this
case and in general SARSA is to be
considered an on policy algorithm
because if you look at the pseudo code a
little bit more closely we are defining
our policy as the epsilon greedy policy
and we are indeed improving this same
epsilon greedy policy right so the
policy will change over time and you're
correct uh but we are indeed going to be
improving the same policy that is being
used to interact with the environment
>> [snorts]
>> So yeah, SARSA is indeed an policy
algorithm. But so let us now dig a
little bit deeper into uh of policy
learning. Uh how do we define it
slightly more formally and also why do
we ultimately care about of policy
learning. [snorts] So in general of
policy learning is the can be seen as
the mechanism through which we want to
evaluate uh target policy pi
that is we want to compute the
associated value functions for this
target policy pi while following a
behavior policy mu uh that is a
different policy specifically the data
we'll use to define our update equations
will basically be sampled by
interactions in the environment that are
collected by following the behavioral
policy mu.
Right? So the data here is obtained uh
by observing a different policy.
So why would
being able to do something like this be
useful? So first of all um in some cases
for example you know robotics to be uh
to be one uh it might we might not have
the luxury of uh actually interact with
the real world or with the environment
infinitely many times right maybe in
some cases we can only learn through
either observations of uh humans or
other agent doing things and therefore
kind of having this framework whereby we
are able able to evaluate and learn
about a different policy from the one
that is the one that generated the
observations is actually a nice thing to
have.
kind of a second reason uh is that so
far so remember our generalized policy
iteration scheme we described these
alternating processes where we are
gradually improving our policy over time
right and so if you see this now a
little bit more holistically in the
environment we are generating data
according to changing and hopefully
sequentially improving uh policies
versions of the same policy Right. And
so far we were basically saying that we
have some uh interactions with the
environment and we only use the most
recent versions of those interactions to
update our values. Right? So all of the
previous data that was generated from
the previous versions of my policies, we
were basically throwing it away, right?
And so I hope it's uh you know it's
pretty evident that this might be
wasteful, right? So maybe there is some
information to be gained from uh
previous data
and lastly so this is slightly more
subtle point but also I think the reason
why off policy methods are also best
known for um and it is because by
decoupling if you wish the behavior
policy from the target policy we're
essentially able to posit the problem
where we want to learn about the optimal
policy
that is likely to be you know an an
exploiting policy typically
deterministic from the exploratory
policy which is the one that is maybe a
little bit more random and free of
exploring our environment
but so I think these are all great
reasons for which uh of policy learning
is actually uh is actually very
important
so now let's look back at what we were
doing for SARSA where we were basically
updating our Q functions in an on policy
way and let's see how we could modify
what we were doing in SARSA in order to
basically follow this off policy uh
paradigm.
So remember that in Sarsa we were using
um behavior policy mu. So here we're
already using the new notation to
generate um our quintuple of events
right specifically the state and control
at time t the reward and the next state
and then we're also using it to generate
the the next control.
However, now let's consider an
alternative successor action U t +1
prime which is generated from our target
policy. All right, if we were to use now
this quintuple of events in defining the
update, this was essentially represent
a way in which we are updating our Q
function Q towards the value of the
alternative action. Right? So if you
look a little bit more closely at what
we're saying here is that we are
updating our Q function
for XTUT by taking a step in the
direction of the TD target defined by
the the value of the alternate action UT
prime T + 1 prime.
Now basically the formalization of this.
So how do we kind of if we want to now
instantiate this idea into a working
algorithm this would directly lead us
into defining Q-learning. Right? So
specifically in Q-learning we would
define the target policy pi [snorts] as
the greedy policy with respect to Q.
Again the target policy is the policy we
wish to learn and we are interested in
learning the optimal policy. So we want
to learn the greedy policy with respect
to Q. So the target policy for us is the
argmax over Q
and we define the behavior policy to be
the epsilon greedy policy. So in this
case we are acting in some cases
randomly with respect to our Q function.
But you see how we are formally defining
these two different policies. The one
that we use to interact with the
environment and the one we actually care
about uh learning.
So by basically taking uh looking at the
TD target in this case. So remember that
the from the in the previous slide we
basically said that in this formalism
where we have a behavior policy and a
target policy the update and
specifically the TD target essentially
looks at the reward plus the discounted
value Q function evaluated in the
alternative action UT plus one prime.
So if we just take this same TD target
which is basically this term over here
and apply our definition of how we
compute the uh alternative actions
according to our target policy. We
basically get uh we only would modify
this term inside the Q function namely
the argmax over our Q function.
And by just doing some you know
algebraic manipulations we would
basically get that this is equivalent to
uh defining the TD target as the reward
plus the discounted maximum Q value uh
where the maximum is taken under the
action U.
Right? So here we're evaluating the Q
value
under the arg max where the control is
taken under the arg max over Q and so
this means that the overall value will
be maximized right because we're taking
U in order to maximize Q and so this is
just can just be written as the max over
Q
all of this to say is that we by
following this formalism we basically
redefine our TD target
in this way over here. Meaning we're
just replacing our TD target by
defining it according to the uh
alternative successor action. In this
case, the alternative successor action
action is the argmax policy. And so this
is what it leads to essentially.
any any questions here?
Okay.
And so basically now if you put this
together into a working algorithm you
would basically get uh what is referred
to as Q-learning. Exactly. So again we
initialize our policy. Um we start our
learning loop whereby we we are
initialized in some state XT. Um we take
we we basically choose a control UT in
this state XT according to an epsilon
greedy policy. This is our behavior
policy which we chose.
Um and we observe the reward and the
next state according to this control.
Now we basically have all of our
elements in order to define the update
which we derived in the previous slide.
Right?
And so we can just repeat over time
until we uh converge. Yes.
>> The behavior policy only
sorry
behavior policy first.
Okay. Sorry.
>> Oh yes. Yes. So
>> yeah. Yeah. So in this case we are using
the behavior policy in our environment.
Specifically we this generates the first
and then we are kind of fictitiously
assuming that we would take this uh this
this action over here.
>> Yeah.
>> Sorry. Where does this
where does this come from? What policy?
>> Uh so this is so here we're defining uh
two different policies. one is a
behavior policy which interacts with the
environment and one is a target policy
which we which is the one we care about
learning essentially. So in this case
the this U T+1 prime is sampled from
this target policy. So here this is in
general [clears throat] terms. So we are
arbitrarily talking about behavior
policy mu and target policy pi. Uh but
in specifically when we look at
Q-learning the target policy is the
greedy policy. So taking the argmax and
the behavior policy is the epsilon
greedy policy. So we randomly act uh we
act randomly epsilon% of the time.
So putting this together we indeed
follow the epsilon greedy policy in our
environment but then in our updates we
are basically
updating our Q functions towards the
value of the successor action.
Does this clarify?
So there is some of course there's
theory that have been developed for all
of these algorithms SARSA included. Um I
I I thought it would have been nice to
just mention the fact that uh it can be
proven that uh according under some
regularity assumptions uh Q-learning
does indeed converge to the optimal
action value function and therefore that
this process essentially uh leads to
learning the optimal policy accordingly.
Okay. So
I think that basically these differences
and these discussions that we're doing
between behavior policies and uh target
policies can be a little bit confu
confusing at first. So let's try to
uh build some intuition into by looking
at the difference in a simple
environment between what we did before
with SARSA and what we're doing right
now with uh Q-learning.
So let's look at this modified version
of the grid world whereby again we want
to go from a start position to a goal
position. Um no wind in this case so no
disturbance but now we are assuming we
have this basically failure region uh
which is the cliff over here which is
basically something extremely negative
for our agent. Right? So the reward here
is again encoding minimal time so
negative one at all time steps. But if
you do end up falling in the cliff, then
that's that's then then you're doomed.
Uh so negative 100 specifically and with
a specific choice of hyperparameters.
So as a spoiler um if you wish here we
are com comparing the
policies that we would be converging to
if we followed uh SARSA in blue or uh
Q-learning in red.
However, kind of the if you look at the
kind of training dynamics over here, you
would basically again here we're looking
at on the x-axis the episodes and on the
y-axis we're now looking at the sum of
rewards that we acrew over episodes.
And from here you would actually say
that SARSA is indeed performing better
than curate. Right? So
the catch here is that if you think back
at our discussion on on policy and off
policy algorithms, SARSA being an on
policy algorithm is essentially learning
the best version of its u kind of
exploratory policy if you wish right so
uh as we defined it we were following
this epsilon greedy policy and so SARSA
indeed converges to the optimal epsilon
greedy policy.
On the other hand, Q-learning because we
are kind of detaching our behavior from
the target of learning uh converges to
the optimal policy by style. So this is
kind of if you wish kind of by induction
a property of one being on policy and
one being off policy.
Now why would this explain this behavior
over here?
The reason is that in our environment,
remember that both algorithms act
epsilon greedily, right? So
if you act according to the red policy
and you're epsilon greedy, then
sometimes you will actually be doing
some random things and fall in the
cliff, right? And so this is why
Q-learning
when we kind of log what we're doing
over training, we have a lower score. On
the other hand, SARSA because it in
order to account for this uncertainty of
its epsilon greediness
kind of converged to the optimal epsilon
greedy policy which in this case is a
safer one that basically would would
travel more closer to the ceiling.
>> Yeah.
>> Is it generally the case that SARS will
converge to a quote safer?
So I I would say this is specific of
course to this specific choice of
hyperparameters and how we are
discussing it in general. Of course you
can modify the algorithm of SARSA for
example by having a decay schedule of
your epsilon greediness and then you can
also converge to uh to the optimal
policy.
So of I mentioned theory for Q-learning
that this converges to the optimal
policy. There's theory de developed also
for SARSA in the fact that according to
indeed some specific choice of uh your
epsilon DK strategy or more generally um
some specific property of your
randomness in your policy and some
conditions on your step size also
converges to the optimal policy.
>> Yeah.
Why does
really converging
lower
despite taking a shorter path? And why
does the I mean both are not passing
through the clips. So why does
>> No, I think it's worth looking at this
uh closer and making sure we we're all
on the same page. So here we're just um
visually depicting kind of the optimal
kind of strategies that both algorithms
converge to right so we learn some Q
functions and if we act greedily with
respect to those Q functions this is how
the two algorithms would behave now at
training time we're not acting greedily
with respect to those Q functions but
we're acting epsilon greedily right so
with some epsilon percent we're doing
some random action
If you consider the fact that Q-learning
is actually going closer to the cliff in
some epsilon percent of the time we
would be landing in the cliff and so
this is giving it some negative uh
reward during training right so these
logs are measuring the performance of
the epsilon greedy application of the
two Q functions that we're learning
>> this also reward
the first step or it's just the reward
that's
>> uh you mean what is being tracked here
>> that's reward
>> yes so here we are assuming that for
every time step in our environment we
whatever we do it's minus one until we
reach the goal
>> and then if we fall in the cliff we get
negative 100 and it it terminates and we
respond back to the start
>> okay so even though during the training
the some of the rewards in the service
is a little tricky learning cuz it it's
the more often during
those policy
the actual pack that converges to the is
I guess higher in reward the path
>> yeah this is very important doesn't it
make sense why these two paths are
visualizing
we so these forget what happens during
training training is done and we
converge to two different Q functions is
this path is visualizing being greedy so
argmax over those Q functions and this
is what you would do
now
here what we're saying is during
training time so before doing this
visualization what you would see is is
this u basically this plot over here why
would you see this difference is because
at training time you're not acting
greedily with respect to your Q function
but you're acting epsilon greedy
Oh, sorry. Yeah.
>> Did you do the epsilon?
>> No. So, here is just fixed
hyperparameters.
>> And if you did have
uh
>> Yeah. So, SARSA would converge to the
optimal policy as well.
>> Yeah.
Okay. Any any other questions on uh on
what we discussed so far before we move
on to uh function approximation?
Okay, great.
So until now um
we discussed algorithms that were
basically deployed on these smaller
scale uh you know toy- like uh worlds
right on the other hand uh I'm sure kind
of most of you or or some of you at
least might have heard about uh kind of
the great successes of reinforcement
learning both in the realm of games for
example Alph Go and kind of the
successes in Go are one of the peaks of
the successes at least with respect to
games. Um,
but these are all environments where if
you think about the state space, uh,
these are incredibly large and
incredibly high dimensional, right? So,
for example, in the game of Go, you
could have 10 to the^ 170 different
configurations of the board, which is, I
think, more than the atoms in the
universe or something like that. So, uh,
this is an incredibly high number,
right? And you could argue that games
are actually among the easier things to
solve compared to, you know, having
things deployed in the real world,
right? Where things that could happen
are are much more uh highdimensional
even.
And so the question is how can we scale
what we're saying with u with this model
free uh reinforcement learning
approaches um to these more
highdimensional systems.
And the culprit here in scaling will
essentially be to move away from our
tabular expression of value functions.
Again remember that we are essentially
in everything that we did so far we were
assuming that the value functions or Q
functions
equally were essentially represented as
lookup tables. Right? So essentially for
each value of our state or state action
pair we will have a specific entry which
represents the value of that state or
state action pair. On the other hand
and and and this is of course
problematic as I'm sure you can imagine
for two main reasons. The first one is
memory. So if you know if you have 10 to
the^ 170 states then you know even just
storing this is an issue. But then for
the perspective of learning there is a
clear curse of dimensionality issue that
comes up uh because to update values in
our lookup tables we have to visit those
uh entries in the lookup tables. And so
you can imagine how this becomes uh
problematic.
So this is where um kind of value
function approximation comes uh comes in
play and this is because and basically
where the main idea is that rather than
defining these lookup tables um we want
to define a parametric function with
some parameters theta that basically
approximates uh our values. Right? So we
will be moving from these tabular
representations to something where the
value function is basically a parametric
function parameters theta that in this
case maps from states to uh a real value
and you can imagine something very
similar for the Q function right again
this is a
[snorts] uh it's just a function that
basically maps
from uh states and controls to real
values. Right?
So first of all, how does these this
idea address these two issues? First of
all, um we are
um compressing or if you wish amortizing
the memory storage cost in storing only
the parameters, right? So we're not
storing one value for each state action
pair but we're only storing the values
of our parameters.
And also in terms of addressing the
course of dimensionality to some extent
we can hope that these value uh
approximations can generalize across
states and state action pairs. Right?
So, so far even in our grid world
examples, we were assuming that we had
like a goal state G
and that
uh even very nearby states if we wish to
estimate the value of this nearby state
to the goal, we would have to visit this
state. On the other hand, you can
probably hope that in the general case,
as long as your representation of your
environment is correct, this kind of
knowing something about the goal state
could also inform your estimate of the
value uh close by the gold state. And so
this is something that we can hope to
have uh when we look at a function
approximation.
Okay, how does function approximation
look in practice for uh value functions?
Here is where there could be uh many
different ways of instantiating uh value
functions through a function
approximation. At the high level um I
think most implementations pick between
one of these three representations. Uh
in general we are assuming that we have
a black box that it basically represents
our function approximation with some
parameters theta. But in general we
could have these three main classes. The
first one is if you're estimating value
state value functions V, it will be
something that takes as input a state X
does some computation and then uh spits
out a value for that state. Similarly,
uh the a Q function could be something
that takes as input a state and a
control and spits out the specific Q
function for the state and control pair.
Or another interpretation of this uh
second um approach would be something
that we still want to estimate the Q
function but now we take as input only
the state and rather than generating one
output we would be generating uh
multiple outputs one for each possible
control in that state.
Can you imagine why? I'm not saying this
is better in general, but can you
imagine why this might be desirable
compared to the second one?
>> Yeah.
>> Include in your function kind of or
maybe use inputs that you could define
the function in terms of you natively
maybe.
>> So I think your your intuition is
correct. Now doing this for continuous
um action spaces is challenging right uh
depending on discretization but I would
not go for this when you have a
continuous uh control space uh but I
think you're correct in the sense that
this could lead to some simplification
in how you represent Q right but can you
so assume both both X and U are discrete
in our case can you think of a reason
why yeah
want to have multiple functions like if
you were looking at driving a car
somewhere
gas
um I would argue probably not know at
least at face value because remember
that we will be positing this as a
learning problem or as a regression
problem right so either here you are
assuming that you have different target
Q functions that you're willing to
wanting to estimate and then maybe
indeed this could be helpful. Um but
let's assume for now that we have one a
value function of one policy that we
that we wish to estimate but I think
yours is a good intuition but not what I
was uh looking here right now.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean sort of let's just probe in one
specific state and then we can take the
artifacts over all the cues that output
to get the
>> Yes. Exactly. Exactly. So I think these
are all all great points but here I was
more thinking about indeed kind of more
of a computational aspect if you wish.
So remember that we are defining our
policy generally or at least the greedy
policy once we have learned the Q
function as an argmax over u. Now say
that we have again u is discrete. So we
have a finite number of u we want to
iterate over. If we had now a function
approximation for our uh Q function,
this becomes an optimization problem if
you wish, right? So before it was just
basically looking up in a table, now
it's an optimization problem. So um if Q
our Q function is something that given a
state only gives us the value of um
given a state and a control gives us one
value we would have to do
n queries where n could be very high
right on the other hand if q is an
object that given an x gives us all the
values of u of of qxu for all u's then
this becomes again uh kind of a lookup
in a finite number of elements if I'm
with only one call.
Again, I'm not saying this is the best
way for going for it, but you know,
these are um
kind of insights behind these these
choices.
And then not only is there of course
flexibility in how you define these
function approximations at the high
level but also within the uh blackbox
you know you know creativity is is king
here right. So in some sense you could
go with something very simple such as a
linear model or something very complex
such as an extremely deep uh neural
network but the uh high level
understanding remains the same.
Okay. Okay, so I hope I have convinced
you about the benefits of uh value
functions approximations. How do we
instantiate
um what we've been saying so far in
terms of uh Monte Caro learning and TD
learning when we have uh value functions
where we have um parametric functions
that represent our uh value functions.
So remember that now what we want to do
is essentially learn the parameters
theta of our uh value functions
approximators that is we want to
minimize the error between the estimated
value for example v theta of x. Um so
the error we want to minimize this error
between v theta of x and the true value
v pi of x.
Seeing this from a regression
perspective, this would mean potentially
positing this objective function J or
cost function J. And we want to minimize
the expected value of this error, right?
So we want to minimize like the mean
squared error for example.
How do we solve this? We have done this
multiple times. For example, by taking
gradient descent, right? So um where we
want to define
essentially
some delta some displacement in our
parameters of our function
approximations which goes in the
direction of the negative gradient.
Now if we
were to pick this choice of uh of
displacement delta t what we would
basically get doing some some math is
something such as we are basically
taking one step where we choose some
step size alpha
um in the direction of u basically our
uh negative gradient multiplied by this
uh error over here right
and I definitely suggest you to
basically go through the derivation of
how we go from from here to here. But
this is not very insightful. It's just
basically applying gradient descent
stoastic gradient descent to this
objective.
But at the high level, it's important to
basically fix in your mind that the form
of our updates in our parameters is
something that looks like this.
Now, how we described it so far, it's
kind of a chicken and egg and an egg
problem, right? Because we're saying we
want to minimize the error between our
prediction and our true value function,
but we don't have the true value
function, right?
And so in in practice uh what we do here
is we basically leverage everything that
we said so far in um when we talked
about TD targets and Monte Carlo targets
in order to define what is our target
for regression essentially. So similar
to how we did in tabular methods, we
would have like a version of the Monte
Carlo update where now we are taking
we're updating the parameters of our
function in the direction of minimizing
the prediction error where this
prediction error is between our
prediction and the ground truth return
estimated as we were doing through Monte
Carlo.
And in TD learning, what we would get is
the same thing, but now instead of
pointing at the ground uh the observed
return, we're basically pointing at the
TD target, right? Where we're using our
estimate of future values as well.
Okay. So what are we really saying here?
So we
are basically saying two different
versions of uh a very similar intuition
right. So we said um in the tabler
dimension where value functions are
lookup tables, we were using
interactions with our environment to
estimate either a return simply the sum
of all the rewards that we saw or a TD
target, right? [snorts] So the immediate
return reward plus the estimate future
value.
In the tabular case, we were then simply
using these two quantities to update
individual entries in our lookup table
according to our um update equations.
When we're looking at function
approximation at the high level, we're
doing exactly the same thing, but now
instead of updating entries in lookup
tables, we're using those same
quantities. the return GT and the TD
target to basically
uh define
um input output pairs for our regression
problem,
right? And so this means that we will be
able to define some updates to our
parameters theta in a very similar way.
Does this make sense?
Any questions here?
Yeah.
>> Yes. So this is a is a great intuition
because indeed um
as you say kind of the quality of my
target evolves over time the more this
is getting better and so uh I you are
actually pointing at I would say one of
the key
engineering breakthroughs if you wish
that enable deep like deep reinforcement
learning to actually work in practice uh
basically stabilizing learning exactly
for this reason um and I think we'll
mention it in uh in a couple of sites.
Yeah, but this is a great intuition.
Okay, of course again here we mentioned
everything um in looking at state value
functions. Uh but everything holds
exactly the same when we look at Q
functions. So again the kind of
underlying regression problem that we
would like to solve is basically
minimizing the error between the
predicted uh Q function and the ground
truth Q function uh which leads to
defining a specific update in parameter
space. We are of course uh not able to
observe the ground truth Q function and
so we define uh the target of our
regression either through Monte Carlo or
TD learning. In this case, if we were to
use a TD target, we would get what is
referred to in eliciter as fitted Q
iteration.
And so kind of indeed implementing this
uh in within our uh kind of generalized
policy iteration scheme could look like
something where at the policy evaluation
stage, we basically approximate uh the Q
function of our policy by uh using these
update equations in parameter space that
we just defined. Namely, we interact
with the environment, collect some data
and fit that data, fit the Q function
that better estimates those TD targets.
And so this is what policy evaluation
looks like for us. And then we use the
updated um Q function to basically
define our epsilon greedy policy
improvement step.
Again, I hope that even through
the repetition of very similar versions
of those same algorithms, you're
starting to see how different RL
algorithms are all built around uh
different instantiations of Monte Car
learning and TD learning and basically
swapping or mixing different elements in
those updates.
But this would indeed be um a working uh
reinforcement learning algorithm with um
value function approximation.
How does this look like in our
reinforcement learning skeleton?
Remember that last time we were starting
to introduce this bird's eye view on
basically all reinforcement learning
algorithms out there defined as a first
stage where we generate samples. A
second stage where we either fit a model
of our dynamics or estimate some return
and use this to improve the policy.
Indeed, if we look at fitted Q-learning,
which is what we just uh described, we
would run the policy and observe our
usual transitions.
We would then use this data to uh define
a target for our uh Q function
regression problem if you wish.
Specifically here we're using the TD
target
and then use this to um basically update
our estimate of the Q function
and then we use the newly learned Q
function to improve the policy according
to an ARGMAX policy improvement.
Okay, any any questions here?
Okay. So then the last thing that I
wanted to discuss today relates with um
basically taking these ideas but now
looking at kind of modern instantiations
of these ideas specifically in the field
of like deep reinforcement training that
is using deep neural networks within the
same algorithms uh that we just
discussed today.
And one of the I would say
groundbreaking results uh I think this
dates back to roughly 2014 is uh is
known as deep Q networks or DQN for
short. Uh and we saw this uh I think a
couple of times before we saw these
videos of these Atari games. But the
point here is that indeed the goal of
where these algorithms were developed
was solving uh basically learn how to
play optimally different versions of the
Atari family of games. Uh specifically
kind of the interesting side of this is
that we were basically using deep
neuronet network specifically at the
time convolutional neuronet networks to
learn how to control these games
directly from images. And so this is
where the power of if you wish deep
learning and reinforcement learning was
starting to be combined. And at a high
level kind of the
architecture of these methods looked
something like we have kind of raw
images of our environment which we are
processing through multiple layers of
convolutional neural networks and then
we are outputting here at least in the
original instantiation
um one value for each of the possible
actions that we could do in this state.
So if you wish the image for us is a
proxy or observation of what the state X
is and so we have the state coming in in
the form of an image and we have the Q
value for all of the use all of our
controls in this state. So if you
remember from our three different
categories of value function
approximation this would be the last the
third one.
So in some way this work indeed used uh
deep neuron nets to represent uh our Q
functions and as we will see in the next
slide this introduced a number of tricks
that uh basically helped to stabilize
learning when we look at uh deep neural
networks exactly as your colleague was
assuming before.
Is this uh picture clear more or less
what the algorithm is doing?
Yeah. Okay. So, let's look more
specifically at these two um um kind of
these two solutions that that were I
would say extremely important for
actually uh the the success of these
methods. And we're specifically talking
about experience uh replay and uh what
is known as uh using fixed uh Q targets.
So indeed these two ideas turned out to
be extremely uh important to stabilize
uh training uh because they basically
addressed two main issues. The first one
is that
right now if we're looking at uh
function approximation uh in our of our
Q functions we basically have this inner
loop which is the basically regression
of our Q function. Right? So as we
explore in our environment, we basically
are iteratively fitting the estimates of
our Q function to the targets that we
are observing.
However, in this case, um because we are
active agents in our environments, kind
of samples over time in our rollouts are
highly correlated with each other,
right? And and this is of course uh very
bad from a perspective of um regression
and supervised learning because we know
that kind of statistical learning theory
usually assumes that data is iid from a
target distribution.
And so the one big issue is that because
we are now in a interactive um
engagement with our environment um the
targets and the samples that we observe
are highly correlated with each other.
The second problem is indeed uh what
your colleague was referring to which is
that the target that we are aiming
towards to that we are regressing
towards to is indeed the moving target
because as we update the parameters
theta then the target of our regression
also changes and so this creates some
some problems and uh in terms of
stability.
So let us look at uh how these two
issues were solved in in in practice.
So at a very high level I would say the
learning loop of DQN goes as follows.
So as usual we are you know in a
specific state XT and we take an action
UT according to the epsilon BD policy.
Again the policy initially might be a
randomly initialized neural net
as we are doing kind of classically in
Q-learning. We store this transition of
uh xt ut reward and next state and we
store it in a replay memory uh
calligraphic.
Now part so here is where the kind of
the solution to the first problem
actually comes in place which is
arguably very simple but it's
essentially saying that we know that the
problem that we are we want to fix is
that data and individual transitions are
highly correlated between each other. So
let's decorrelate transitions by storing
them in a buffer and then rather than
using only the most immediate
transitions let us s sample these uh
individual transitions from that buffer.
Assuming the buffer is large enough then
this would you the more this the buffer
grows the more the individual
transitions are um decorrelated with
each other
right? So what we're saying is that if
we were to look at a single rollout,
we would generally observe a situation
where we have XT UT and the associated
reward and we have the next state XT +
one which gives us like the first
transition
and then and so we could use this to
make one update. in our algorithm,
right? But then as we move along in our
episode, we would basically be observing
some new transitions
which are highly correlated with the
previous one, right? And so if we were
to take these transitions online and
sequentially, these would be highly
correlated with each other. What we're
saying at least with this experience
replay idea is that rather than using
these transitions directly, we observe
them uh store them in a buffer which is
something that you know it's just a you
know large data set of uh of transitions
right something that is is a collection
of these
um transitions
and XT + one
and by sampling from this buffer we are
basically decorrelating uh the
transitions that we that we use to fit
our networks.
So again very simple idea but I think
quite quite powerful in accomplishing
what it was trying to do.
Now the second trick entails stabilizing
this [snorts] moving target uh issue
that we were highlighting before right
and the idea here is to basically
leverage two copies of the same uh value
function network. So instead of having a
single network Q theta we're basically
working with two different networks Q
theta and uh Q fi. So we have two copies
of the parameters.
The point in
in this uh solution is essentially that
we will have one copy of the parameters
that we are updating uh over time and
one copy that is basically a delayed
version of that um of that function that
we're updating. So we start with some
randomly initialized to the same thing
uh policy. So two copies of the same
initialized network.
Now imagine that we have uh this is like
a time axis over training. We would have
a phase where we are initially updating
theta and we are updating theta on fixed
uh right. So over here five is actually
fixed.
Now
fi is could be horribly bad at
estimating the values at the beginning
but from the perspective of stability of
the target this is actually stable
because it's consistent over time.
Right?
Of course over time we will be kind of
defining some regular cadence where we
are basically
updating the parameters fi to the
potentially most recent version of theta
right and so we repeat this so then we
have a new phase where we are updating
theta but now towards a slightly better
version of the target network again fi
here remains fixed
And then we repeat over time. So you see
that in general we basically instantiate
this delayed version of the same Q
network um which stabilizes the um the
target through this um kind of delayed
uh update.
Of course different versions vary of the
algorithm vary in how this update is
done. This is a very
uh deterministic way of updating the um
target policy Q5.
It's been shown that this specific
version could uh is probably not the
best choice because there could be a
jump a too harsh jump in updating those
the parameters of our target file. So I
would say probably right now the most
popular version is referred to as polyac
averaging where it's basically a moving
average of the parameters. So if you
wish exact same iterations apply but the
update of our target network QI is not
done in a so kind of harsh kind of step
fashion way but it's fi will be a moving
average of previous versions of of steer
but this this is exactly the idea and so
you see that
I would say these two contributions were
basically key in uh making deep
reinforcement learning algorithms work
in practice.
Does this make sense? Any any questions
here?
Okay. So, this wraps up concludes our
discussion of value based methods. Um
next week uh we'll be discussing uh
policy optimization based methods again
model 3 and then we'll move for our last
lecture on uh model based reinforcement
learning methods. See you next week.